bring in senior political analyst brit
hume good evening britt i want to talk
to you about the hunter biden story
we've talked about the media angle here
but obviously this investigation is
continuing here's another piece of chuck
grassley today
we can only expose the records that show
that 5 million dollars went from people
in china
to the biden hunter bite we just follow
the money and the facts where they lead
us and we aren't done with this yet
we'll probably be making some more
revelations
yet this week in
senate speeches and we'll be looking for
those revelations what do you make of
this story
well i think it's pretty clear brett
that
you know it's not just allegations of
influence peddling i mean clearly hunter
biden was peddling whatever influence
was available to him through his father
um you know they didn't hire hunter
biden because of his you know his noted
skills in any particular areas as sun
whatever else he may be is a pretty
dissolute character who's never really
distinguished himself in any way and
would be an unlikely person for a
foreign government or foreign
governments to hire to help them in
washington he was hired obviously
because his father was at the time vice
president
and for the president uh now to say that
well he never knew anything about he
said this all along he never do anything
about his his son's business dealings or
his brother's business dealings uh in
the same arenas
it's a little hard to hard to to believe
after all you know hunter biden flew
into china with the vice president on
air force two what did he what did they
have the whole trip and and the father
never asked his son what he was doing
over there i mean you know it it it just
doesn't hold together
yeah and and the washington post uh
comes out over the weekend with this
kind of contrition the hundred biden
story is an opportunity for a reckoning
uh wise confirmation of a story that
first surfaced in the fall of 2020
emerging only now twitter blocked the
story altogether facebook down ranked
the story and algorithms this series of
events has prompted allegations of a
cover-up or at best a double standard
the lesson learned from 2016 was
evidently to err on the side of setting
aside questionable material in the heat
of a political campaign the lesson
learned from 2020 may be well that there
is a danger of suppressing accurate and
relevant stories that's from the
editorial board of the washington post
which by the way the header is democracy
dies in darkness in darkness right well
when is it
when is it not a bad idea to suppress
accurate and relevant stories it always
is of course and this was as it turns
out and we all a lot of us thought so at
the time an accurate and relevant story
that in the new york post with lots of
detail lots of facts alleged and in the
mainstream media it's not just twitter
and facebook which disgracefully refused
to allow the story to appear
on their sites but it was also
newspapers including the washington post
and notably the new york times as well
other mainstream media outlets that
refuse to follow up on it as you
normally would do another publication
another news outlet breaks the story
it's a
relevant story in the middle of a
political campaign allegations are
serious you can run them down and and
you know we don't make a blanket
judgment without investigating as to
whether the story is true or false or
valid or not that's not what happened
here and of course you had those
intelligence ex-intelligence agents and
officials 50 or so of them that came out
and and said that it's smacked of
russian disinformation we now know it
certainly was not and that they're
saying so with pure speculation and you
know politically motivated i think it's
pretty clear and i think the newspapers
and others that that covered this story
up refused to follow it up or
did so for political reasons as well
they did not want joe biden to lose to
donald trump and that was the bottom
line and quickly uh brit
you're a
avid twitter user do you think twitter
changes with elon musk as its largest
shareholder
i think so and i think that's a good
thing i think it'll be a more open
platform and this kind of monkey shines
that they've been doing um where they
suppress certain stories and cancel
people and shut them down and so forth
needs to go away look uh whether you're
a fan of donald trump or not it's not a
good idea for the former president
united states not to speak on you know
one of the most important uh
communications platforms in america
which twitter certainly is uh and
profits from being so i i think that
things may change at twitter i noticed
that one one twitter
big shot said he was quitting because he
didn't want to work for elon musk and i
suspect that in the eyes of many that's
good news all right brett as always
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else